um we all know that you have all those
really crazy ideas in the best way
possible but how do you come up with
those ideas could you tell me more about
your process and also once you have
those great ideas how do you go about
capitalizing those really ambitious
ideas if you have very few limited
financial resources the the great thing
about so software or anything which just
involves intellectual capital you a
couple of you and your friends are you
and a few friends is that you can just
do it so that's why I'm there doing some
sort of internet thing or software thing
is great as an initial company to create
that's why it's zip - and PayPal they
gave me the capital to attempt to do
more capital intense activities I mean
in as far as idea generation I think I
tend to think of things from sort of
physics standpoint like from a first
principle standpoint what would be the
best way to accomplish something and
then pursue that so and that's also a
good way to determine if there's a if if
something is far from its optimum and
like on rockets for example one could
say oh you know that you could reason by
analogy and say the Rockets gonna cost a
certain amount because that's what prior
Rockets have cost or you can say well
what is a rocket made of what are the
material constituents
what are those mister what are they
weigh what's the cost per unit mass and
that that sets the limit asymptotically
for what a rocket can be so if you can
figure out some creative way to
rearrange those elements into a rocket
shape then you can achieve a much better
outcome that's the first principles
approach and I think also just combining
ideas from different industries is
really helpful for innovations so what
do people discovered in one industry and
cannot be applied to other industries
that's I think also a great source of
ideas
but usually just struggle on a solution
and you try try a bunch of things some
of them don't work and some of them and
most of them don't work and occasionally
one does